comment soigner un astronaute à distance
celle agence spatiale européenne qui
mène en ce moment une expérience sans
précédent plusieurs volontaires se sont
isolés depuis trois semaines
six candidats spationaute et ils sont
installés à bergen en norvège
aujourd'hui on a simulé un cas très
précis une affection qui nécessitait une
intervention urgente
les médecins étaient à toulouse est
relié à leurs malades par télévision un
reportage
jeanne kazan en norvège six hommes
isolés dans un caisson hyperbare à
l'hôpital purpan à toulouse trois
médecins spécialistes des soins à
distance tous ces acteurs se sont
rencontrés avant l'expérience car la
télémédecine passe par la formation
formation pour celui qui joue le rôle du
malade formation pour l'assistance
sanitaire c'est lui qui décrit les
symptômes dont souffre le patient pour
que le médecin puis à distance établir
un diagnostic avant de traiter la
nouveauté un système expert mis au point
à l'université paul sabatier à toulouse
qui permet aux isolés de bergen d'être
guidés en temps réel dans la pratique de
l'examen du man and une technologie de
pointe pour cet examen médical à
distance une première mondiale
c'est la première fois que l'on peut à
la fois concrétisé dans le même lieu les
amène les conclusions de cet examen le
conseil médical à la fois par voies
auditives et visuelles
quelle sorte qu'on a le maximum de
conditions ou faire un diagnostic est
aujourd'hui un traitement efficace mal à
dissimuler un calcul rénal entraînant
des coliques néphrétiques une pathologie
dont peuvent souffrir les spationautes à
bord des stations orbitales les
différentes données recueillies au cours
de ces expériences de physiologie et de
télémédecine serviront de base pour la
future infrastructure orbitale
européenne des années 2010